so far millions of americans have
received the johnson and johnson vaccine
this pause in its rollout is a setback
but the authorities say people
should not be alarmed we are totally
aware that this is a very rare event
we want to get this worked out as
quickly as we possibly can
and that's why you see the word pause in
other words you want to hold off for a
bit
and very well may go back to that maybe
with some conditions or maybe not
and the makers of the vaccine say whilst
there is uncertainty over its safety
deliveries to europe will be delayed
the us uk and the eu have ordered
hundreds of millions of doses
of the johnson and johnson vaccine of
the nearly 7
million jabs given six blood clots have
been reported
and there's been one death a similar
rare unusual clotting disorder is linked
to the astrazeneca vaccine in europe
and its use has been suspended for some
age groups in several countries
both vaccines work in a similar way by
using
another virus to carry genetic material
from the coronavirus spike protein
into the body the government says what's
happening with the johnson jab
will not affect the rollout of its
national inoculation program
but there are fears that these findings
could increase vaccine hesitancy
and at a time when the coronavirus is
surging once again
in parts of the country
at this center in washington dc which
was administering the j j
vaccine there is some concern but people
lining up
still think getting vaccinated makes
sense
not having your vaccine is a bigger risk
so
i mean i feel like i'd rather take the
vaccine out we'll wait to see about the
johnson vaccine
the initial report sounds like it's a
pretty small percentage you always are
going to feel
a little bit worried about the unknown
but i'm feeling very lucky and
optimistic
the government's health advisors hope
the pause in the johnson and johnson
vaccine will only be
a matter of days and the review
will be made quickly alex rossi sky news
washington